The Lion King is out and as of this
taping is having a tricky time feeling
all the love at 60% fresh the reviews
are still trickling in and really could
go either way at this point but the trek
up this rock is feeling steeper than
expected something the last two Disney
live-action films have also experienced
Dumbo at 46% Rawdon and Aladdin at 57%
rotten could we be facing Disney
live-action fatigue hi everyone I'm Mark
Ellis welcome to the after show yes I
was saying live action in air quotes so
happy to welcome you all to this
particular discussion if you have not
yet seen the new Lion King bear warning
this is a spoiler heavy discussion so be
prepared I am so excited to welcome some
a-list members of the pride here to the
chat ladies and gentlemen
she is a Rotten Tomatoes editor miss
Jacqueline Coley's here oh we get
applause today from and she's geek bomb
host ma Garrett in a very seasonal I
guess for a moment applause well we
saved the best round of applause for
laughs because we're in the presence of
greatness ladies and gentlemen Rotten
Tomatoes editor-in-chief the one the
only mr. Joel Mears is here today oh
this is so exciting to have all y'all
here so what we do on this show is we
like to talk about the movie in depth
but before we get into that discussion I
do want to just pitch it to each
panelist really quick is this movie
fresh or rotten because I go into this
thinking oh well it's Disney it's the
Lion King
of course it's gonna be fresh my opinion
is that it's a very fresh movie I
enjoyed myself start to finish
Jacqueline Coley am I crazy fresh and
this injustice will not stand about this
movie not being fresh as far as I'm
concerned I literally brought out my
tinfoil hat this weekend because it's a
grand conspiracy this is a good movie
y'all don't let the score fool you
alright ma do you agree with that is
this a fresh based on your shirt yeah
it's fresh as I think that the not only
has the the look of this movie matured
but so has my take on it because I'm
seeing and watching this movie from a
whole different perspective of the adult
that's all I'm trying to say okay now
Joel you are also an adult as far as we
know but you are so cheap Rotten
Tomatoes at work
looking at it right now this thing is
barely clinging to Fred this is like
Mufasa on the edge of the cliff and one
star review could come along and knock
it off do you think this is a fresh
movie fresh ish yes so I think I
understand whether it's why the score is
where it's at I enjoyed this film for
what it is I think it's beautiful there
is a lot to recommend it I don't
disagree with anything that's been said
so far although I'm sure I love disagree
and a few minutes with some things that
have said but I didn't feel anything and
I was left a little cold by this Lion
King and I'm not a heartless person I
will cry at the drop of a hat that
subway commercial like it had me in
tears but this film didn't quite get to
the subway level for me you couldn't
feel the lobster dad I didn't feel the
love I felt a little like I'm so happy
mom made that pun for me because I'm
already done with my quota of Lion King
gags okay so do I want to stick with you
for a minute with our first topic which
is are you surprised that the movie is
right at that level of could be fresh
could be run because again this thing
comes out and and even regardless of
what I felt about the movie just seeing
all the ads for the scene the excitement
that fans had for it you would expect
this thing to be up in the 80s or 90s
right I was surprised I don't know that
I was expecting the school to be that
high but the audience I saw but it
certainly was into this film I was
telling the guys earlier the woman next
to me was singing along fist pumping
which made my experience sitting next to
me know the Australian catch but no I
think I was I was surprised that it is
so loud to be honest I was expecting it
to be slightly higher but we have to
understand that this is for many people
going to see this movie particularly
people who do this for a living and have
to think about the industry a lot and
think about the state of culture and art
they're going and seeing this not just
as the Lion King or the Lion King 2019
this thing this is the Lion King the
tenth live-action remake from Disney
since Alice in Wonderland
yes and so this film opens with a huge
amount of baggage because people are
really divided over what Disney is doing
at the moment with these live-action
remakes and the whole concept the whole
nature of this film is divisive to
certain people and that discussion is
really bleeding into the reviews and the
takes that people have this film so I'm
surprised that it's not in the 70's or
May
low 80s but not overly surprised that
there is something of a backlash coming
through
yeah Maude I agree with Joel's point
that I think that a lot of it is just
people's commentary on should we be
having these live-action remakes so the
score being as low as it is is that
something that kind of surprised you Oh
big time and I don't think that it's
fair to a movie a standalone movie to
own and where the baggage of its
predecessors and the decisions that
Disney is making as a company on the
whole I I think
same sort of thing in the cinema for the
world premiere everyone's cheering and
applauding at the end of every scene let
alone Act there's such a great
atmosphere in there I was seeing every
word whatever but I absolutely loved it
and I thought that it looked brilliant
the story was there they kept it
authentic to what the original was
whilst adding new elements to it and I
thought that that really worked Timon
and Pumbaa stole the show for me I
thought that that juror on that upgrade
was fantastic I mean it's not a perfect
film but I absolutely enjoyed it yeah
Jack and I think that that's the other
question that people have is well is
this gonna be as good as the original
simply because we've seen the original
and Maude is able to sing with every
song and maybe it didn't do enough
differently to win critics over is that
why you see that score so low I mean I
have a hard time with it especially with
the critic community that so often sees
a foreign language entry and then an
english-language remake and can equally
like the two of those that's the way I
kind of looked at this I looked at this
as this is a different language meaning
the medium of computer hyper-realistic
photorealistic images that is a
different medium to nmt animations you
were going to lose things by going into
this next medium and you are gonna gain
things by going into this next medium
and I just think when you balance the
two together that's where you kind of
have to basically leave it where it is
and I do think this has a ton of
upgrades I don't know where it sits in
the ledger against the masterpiece that
the first one is I don't think it's fair
to compare the two however I think there
was a lot of care being placed in this
Jon Favreau put a lot of respect to the
original and a lot of deference to the
filmmakers and also to Julie Taymor for
what she did in the stage play play
because this is
just an adaptation of the animated
classic it's also an adaptation of the
stage play and infusing that in
therefore one is a huge upgrade the
knowledge character's storyline is a
huge upgrade regardless of what some of
y'all may think about Beyonce yes I'm a
Stan and so as far as I'm concerned the
movies a masterpiece cos as Beyonce yes
I'll admit it however if that doesn't
mean I can't acknowledge the fact that
Beyonce's a great singer maybe not the
best voice actor you know what I'm
saying like even I can admit that during
the height I know she's great but I do
think when you put her alongside someone
like Billy Eichner who is a tried and
true actor he does this he does voice
acting he literally does improv you
can't compare the two there's separate
roles but you can't write well this
might be the easiest spoiler have you
ever done because if you've seen the
original Lion King you know what's going
to Evan in this movie and it's not
shot-for-shot but it is beat for beat
the big difference obviously being the
photorealistic CGI the it's not even
performance or motion capture I mean
this is rendered by artists and I think
that that being the big difference mod
is is this live-action remake is it
taking enough risks or do you think that
it's supposed to stay with the source
material for this particular film I
think that this is the maybe where they
can do that well because it's not actors
having their own sort of like creative
input you know having their own creative
license with it they have absolute
control over how this looks I think the
problem that you're finding here is that
the choice to make it as realistic as
possible whilst trying to retain the
emotions of the characters that's where
it's falling short a little bit I mean
the beautiful scene where Simba first
eats the the grubs and it has this rough
moment you're not going to see a
realistic line do that because it cannot
physically do that it doesn't have that
emotion and then a little gripe that I
have and I'm so sorry for this but if
you're gonna make a realistic looking
Lion a little cub and hold it up and
there's there's no male parts oh you
wanted to see more I guess this is the
thing where it's like you're making this
choice but then you have to like figure
out where to draw the line aha lion ah
ya know I would say that they drew the
line correct I was just a lot about
online pain was not you have to take a
moment for life but I actually don't
personally feel like they did take
enough risks Jaclyn you mentioned the
stage show I didn't see the stage show
and this this production at all and I
thought they could have really drawn
from that there's a lot of beautiful
music in that stage show there's a lot
of more development that happens in that
stage show and I don't think it was
integrated I felt that February did a
beautiful job of directing and putting
together this replica I don't think they
drew enough and I think the Nala
storyline again I don't think it was
expanded enough I think if you look at
what they did with jasmine and Aladdin
that felt different to me from the
original characterization this Nala they
gave her a bit more like creeping around
the rock with scar and stuff but they
didn't take it nearly as far as they
could have taken it to give us something
that was worth revisiting I feel you
hear the term cash grab thrown around
sometimes too because everybody knows
like if you do this level of the CGI and
it looks as realistic as it did I mean I
think that it did further that evolution
forward but I think that people are
going to say well it's the liking of
course you know you're gonna make
boatloads of money doing this and we've
had three Disney live-action remakes in
the last four months with Dumbo and then
Aladdin and now the Lion King so is the
term cash grab fare Jacqueline I mean
yeah so is any movie that goes as the
box office for certain like idea they
don't put these out because they love us
they put them out to make money I'm so
sorry like if you didn't guess that by
now I don't know maybe you've missed the
whole body something it's a business
yeah it's a business and so yes I think
Disney is making your strategic decision
however you can still do that with care
with integrity you can still do it with
a reverence and a love for the original
you can do both you can say I'm doing
this to make money maybe win some awards
and also because I care and want to give
this new version to a new audience look
I think you can do you can do both in it
it doesn't necessarily why did we make
endgame they wanted it to make money so
I get why people are angry about it I do
think they're picking the wrong
properties to revisit in my personal
view well that's interesting you bring
that up because because those movies
then I reference it have already come
out Dumbo and a lad and both it like I
mentioned the top of the show not as
well received as when Cinderella came
out everybody's like oh great because
there's a great graphic that Rotten
Tomatoes did where you see the lineage
of Disney live-action films as far back
as the 1994 Jungle Book which is fresh
and then we got a little rotten for a
while and then we came back with the
film of the jungle book with all the
animals that Jon Favreau Cinderella
the Allison Wonder Lance take it down a
little bit so it's been through peaks
and valleys but mod it seems like we're
almost going down another valley at this
point big time yeah I think you know
there is such thing as inundation and I
think that when you're not even letting
things mellow we had the same thing with
Star Wars I feel whether it was just
trying to push out as many movies as
possible because it was making so much
money and by the time we got to solo it
was just like I'm not even enjoying this
ride anymore like there is too much of a
good thing that's my defensive suppose
it's not a cash grab because it didn't
grab that much yeah that's it they burnt
it out that was just powder coming out
of them the cash cows so I think yeah if
we just slow the roll a little bit
what's the rush
why do we have to have it all so fast
and you're exactly right there are some
stories that don't need retelling and
Dumbo was one of them let's talk about
the elephant that was captured and made
to perform for people's entertainment
loved that one but wait a minute to your
point though about like I guess this
whole lineage of the live-action how
many they keep going for a studio that
has Marvel that is literally giving you
the blueprint for how to slow roll to a
grand crescendo there are two side
studios being Lucasfilm and Disney
proper they literally do not follow that
formula
yeah they it's all pedal-to-the-metal it
gives me a new reverence for Kevin Feige
strategy and how he's able to maybe push
back well something that Kevin Feige
said I interviewed him recently and what
was amazing was that he only thinks in
five and then ten year increments so
he's not thinking about how we can get
this out month to month it's like really
he thinks in long term strategies and I
think that that's so smart yeah and I
want to get into what we're gonna be
seeing from Disney live-action coming up
Mulan we just saw the trailer for that
that's gonna be a little bit later in
the show but for right now let's move on
to our next topic and Jacqueline I just
want to ask you about the highs and lows
of
movie what I think about what were your
favorite parts what was maybe not the
more of a meow than a roar for you
actually it's interesting so one of the
highs was the Timon and Pumba character
at their relationship Billy Eichner is
definitely going to break out from this
I really feel he got to shine when seth
rogen talks about Billy in the movie
he's like that's just him they captured
him and what those guys could really do
in that booth is really magical and I
think more people should pay attention
to it the lows for me be prepared that
was a you are not in your head in
agreement I think it's a it's a beat
poet rendition of a you know thrilling
Broadway song but doesn't quite land I
will say on the be prepared front could
you imagine though a full version like
the original cuz I think that would just
get weird with those weird faced hyenas
sort of singing along I don't know that
they kind of maybe they should have just
snipped it all together that's the thing
the rumor was they were gonna cut it and
in my personal opinion they should have
they should have made a Braveheart
speech which I think was maybe their
idea what you're trying to prey upon
yeah yeah I mean like we're going to do
this and it's terrible and talk that
Fredo yeah have a rousing moment but
don't put it to use on zebras and [ __ ]
yeah yeah but this is the thing Jeremy
Irons entire character in the 90 for
Lion King is camp for all those people
at the Met Gala that didn't understand
the definition of camp Jeremy Irons in
the Lion King is scar the movies hyper
realistic and gritty and dramatic camp
and realistic are literally the
anticipate of each other so I get why
they they should have cut it out and I
get why they wanted to though I think
they achieved some of that with Timon
and Pumbaa which is interesting because
those two characters were able to go
there but I think their overall
characterization of scar as this more
this darker more serious character
wouldn't allow them to do it I would say
actually overall despite be prepared
being a bit of a phizzer
scar himself was a bit of a highlight
for me and I feel that she would tell
was a beautiful I did a beautiful job
voicing that character I do feel that
more than Nala the the scar
Surabhi relationship was actually one
that I liked seeing fleshed out and felt
added a dimension
alfre woodard also a high but you're
right the own not the only reason but
the big reason to see this film is Timon
and Pumbaa and Billy Eichner I mean he's
gay and fabulous meerkat conquered
enough and emmy-nominated as of this
morning for billions congratulations
Ilya yeah yeah I as soon as Timon and
Pumbaa show up because I love The Lion
King 1994 one but I love it primarily
because of the relationship with Mufasa
and Simba so that first that first act
in the 1994 version is what really drew
me to it mod but seeing this I would
have to agree that I thought Timon and
Pumbaa were highlights but I also
thought that that he the hyena is voiced
by keegan-michael key and Eric Andre
they really made me laugh a lot too I
just like that there was a new take on
it I mean we could have done
play-by-play word-for-word and they
chose not to do that and I liked that
different take that they had on it I
think there's a reason why they had to
change one of the hyenas as well which
was a good thing I'm gonna have to agree
that she would tell Jeffers take on Skye
was great I love Jeremy Irons is version
but I think it's like instead of trying
to mimic or to do exactly the same it
doesn't work make your own version of it
and some of the characters ran with that
and some of the characters really
faltered trying to do that and I think
that scar was great I think it needs to
be camp and I don't think that it like
that I disagree with like having camp
and realistic don't mesh together I
think when you look at the live-action
Beauty and the Beast I think that when
you had every scene with Luke Evans and
Josh garde they went full camp and they
were the best parts of that movie and
then Emma Watson played a little bit
safe and didn't go camp at all and that
juxtaposition that you had its energy
didn't didn't sit there and that's what
you're having in this movie where Chua
tells bringing it Timon and Pumbaa are
going extra camp and then you're having
sort of Nala and adult Simba playing it
very realistic and very safe and they're
not on the same page that's what's
interesting to me is that we're talking
about the highlights right now I have
not heard Donald Glover Beyonce yet
because I felt I didn't think that they
were bad - versus the imagination but I
just felt like I didn't feel any
emotional tinges with their relationship
or even in their individual vocal
performances I thought the performance
of can you feel the love tonight played
very well and a lot of people are upset
it was during the day but I like the
update on it it's not gonna do with the
olden John song does to me but I thought
it was fine he was getting there and
then it stopped I was like I'm in this
and then they sort of like when they cut
out the instruments and it sort of
crescendo and then it just ended I
bought Donald Glover a lot more as this
sort of slacker Simba then I did as the
sort of noble he lives in me kind of I I
definitely liked that aspect of his
performance when he got with Nala and
sort of went back to save the pride it's
that trials a little bit unless this was
he's an army oh he's got mumbled music
you don't need to know the world it's
not the same as the previous yeah my
single line also he's mumble as a rapper
so I'm not surprised he's mumble as a
voice actor either so that doesn't
bother me but in the original the side
characters are just as more interesting
the side characters them always the most
interesting part scar was the most
interesting in the first one and so were
Timon and Pumbaa so they just kept that
over so I'm okay with Nala and Simba not
being is interesting because let's be
honest they weren't to begin with
there's highs and lows with this movie
and there's one that I'm still confused
in my own head I'm trying to rationalize
and that would be the hair scene where
the giraffe eats it and then we send a
giraffe and I'm like I'm watching the
hair blow and I'm like oh great it's
gonna get back to Rafiq and then he's
gonna know but man does that hair take
an interesting off-ramp yeah through a
giraffes intestinal system yeah it went
alright that was yeah very very literal
I found that it was kind of like a
forrest gump feather situation mixed
with just some strangeness for about
what 17 minutes or something I was like
we get it I know what the horoscope you
never see anybody eat the feather then
sitting on the John not in those
chocolates yeah it's like you're seeing
hair remove itself from done and
continue to the dung beetle is cute but
it's I thought that was interesting
I'm not really a wizard it was
interesting because it was like I said
the biggest difference between the films
so I didn't mind that oh can we talk
about the fact that buting the beasts
actually got some of this song in this
movie we've ever seen Disney
he's cross pollinate here and I was so
about it shared universe your boy Kevin
Feige maybe Pixar Pixar always
references each other but Disney proper
right yeah yeah but that was also a
strange thing because this is such a
serious realistic portrayal and then
suddenly he got very like Shrek II kind
of pop-culture reference which I
actually loved but again it's like I
think showed that there were total
inconsistencies that for me a little
that was from the stage play by the way
to stand corrected that was from the
stage play to I don't want to go down
all of the like me and Joel later over
some wine will be like and this was from
the stage play and that was a play but
that was a direct poll when I talked to
John Favreau he mentioned that in the
stage play they reference frozen and
originally they referenced wicked and
they're referencing things that are on
the stage near them on Broadway and
since frozen is now in Broadway they
made that sort of in-joke like in the
live-action were sorry in the stage Lion
King they make that joke and so he
brought over the Beauty and the Beast
one as his little Disney inside
so because Jacqueline is our resident
Broadway expert what did you see
anything in this Lion King that you like
oh that's definitely I recognize that
from the stage play and I'm happy they
did it yes first of all the Sarabi scar
thing is directly ripped from the stage
play gets more Shakespearean and gets
more Claudius the fact that Simba is not
just apathetic but he's more of a
slacker like not even a slacker there's
he doesn't have his stuff together in
the stage play his slackers probably the
wrong word that was more what Donald
brought to it that's directly from it
there's a whole bunch of key touches I
think they pulled some of the I would
say regality to it with the characters
that's definitely from the stage play
there's specific parts of knowledge
dialogue and specific parts of scars
dialogue that I remember specifically
from this there was music they could
have gone with from stage play
everywhere they put the Beyonce song in
amazingly everyone including myself wish
what is it I see the King and you are I
see him in you yeah but we've had a
moment which is a beautiful song that
actually fits the tone of the other
music whereas the Beyonce song is great
but I feel as though it is like that
thing where they throwing in modern song
and it kind of just stands out like a
sore thumb yeah there were some she
wants her Oscar and that's what she did
the movie for
she wants like you know that the she
live in Austria no foxy Cleopatra I
would I would give her an Oscar in
retrospect that performance alone and
Maude we gotta ask you about the musical
selections I want you to kick off this
because what was the highlight musically
for you and you can fall so well wait if
you need I'm that awful person that was
in the movie that as soon as the one
song was done I already was waiting for
the next one and I knew which one it was
and I knew how I was gonna get set up
and it was fantastic for me I loved that
part of it the opening like the very
first shot of this movie was actually
the only one that wasn't animated it was
an actual shot of the the Sun sunrise
coming up so that was beautiful
yep that was great Hakuna Matata
Seth Rogen can't even sing and it
doesn't matter that was so great it
brought so much heart and soul into it
got all of them no I was I even like to
be prepared I think that it was your
toilet break sure but like I I'm just
such a sucker if you were to call it be
prepared the drum solo of this movie I'm
5 of that because I will join you in
that fight I also like the performance
that be prepared Joel your highlights as
far as musicality Greg I thought that
just can't wait to be king was done as
well as they could have done just can't
wait to be king so they sort of said it
around the watering hole it's kind of
playful it's kind of fun baby animals
and stuff the opening number which
everyone's seen in the the trailer very
impressive again I couldn't get out of
my head with it because I was like oh
yeah and this is the shot where the bird
goes along the lake and then this is
this one and the zebra and I'm like but
I couldn't get over it but I thought
just called me to be king was good as I
said can you feel the love tonight had
its moments yeah I think it had his
moments for sure I'm glad you brought up
I can't wait to be came because I think
that might be my highlight I think it
just
hakuna matata was so good and I had such
a showcase to do it and I loved Billy
Eichner right at the end when he he said
he's ripping when he's
so much funny stuff in there so Jack on
the last word on music goes to you I'm
just gonna say them singing Beauty and
the Beast that wasn't meant to be that
huge of a musical cube as far as I was
concerned it gave the best payoff so way
to go and that idea jon favreau well
looking forward to the future of Disney
live-action there's a lot of question
marks now especially again we go back to
the tomato meters score what does this
movie change for you Joel as far as
expectations going forward with the new
Milan movie do you think that now Mulan
obviously it's already in production but
future live-action films I don't think
we're gonna stop getting them do you
think that we're gonna see them stray a
little more from the source material
based on this critical reception I don't
know that it's based on this critical
reception I think that The Lion King is
kind of a kind of it is unique in that
it's perhaps the untouchable property so
there was probably some trepidation
around viewing too far from what is
perhaps the most beloved of the modern
Disney era
I think these films are already in
production and I'm very excited to say
that they do look like they're going to
view a little bit from the source
material so Nicky carros Milan looks
like it's going a more traditional route
moving away perhaps there's no music
perhaps there's no side characters I'm
all about it don't don't get angry me
and a Little Mermaid I mean not only and
I excited that Rob Marshall I believe is
directing it and I thought he did an
amazing job with Mary Poppins justice
for Mary Poppins returns such a great
and underrated film but he's directing
it and we've got what it said in the
Caribbean it's very distinctly set in
the Caribbean which makes a lot of sense
and it's gonna be necessitating a lot of
changes from the original so I'm both
excited about those and I have no issue
with them remaking these films like The
Lion King is a remake of of Hamlet is a
you know which is being done thousands
of times throughout the years Aladdin
Disney did not come up with the Aladdin
story they have a right to retell these
stories my hope is that they find
reasons for us to want to go to the
theatre again and find something fresh
in them and some people will find that
in the Lion King I didn't find the you
know it adequately enough for me but I
you know keep going I'm like do you
worst they want to give us reason to go
to the theatre or they want to give us
reason to subscribe to Disney Plus
because you have lady the [ __ ] is gonna
yeah premiere there and I think that's
even later this year and then you have
sword in the stone which is awesome
production mom oh that was my childhood
right there oh my god those are gonna be
the more successful properties because I
think Disney needs to go away from the
greatest hits the Aladdin's the lion
Kings the Little Mermaid's although I
think it'll be great they need to get
away from these things that are so
beloved and they need to get into the
smaller part with some b-side yeah go
with some b-side like give me some lady
in the trip which is great but can't
compare that to the Lion King can't
compare sword in the stone to Eastern
person yeah so what about the sword in
the stone that gets here me I think it
works very well in you know in animation
obviously with comedy with Monty Python
but I think that is perfectly sourced
for Disney Plus because as John it's a
Jack point it may not grab the wide
audience they would do well if you
release it in theaters but I think that
that gets subscribers that gets people
invested in a streaming service which
again is the future that we're looking
right down the barrel money
it's you've got it you've taken my money
man he Disney have it all I'll watch it
I don't again I don't think that it's
fair to blanket anything when it comes
to Disney properties I think that
they're harnessing it in a case by case
scenario with the Lion King it was
nearly the same movie that we had in
1994 Milan and I am Little Mermaid sound
like it's gonna be very very different
Dumbo was a very different take all
together as well so I think yeah I think
that they're going to apply whatever
strategy is going to work best for that
property I didn't know about spoken
Stone so that's kind of made my day so
let me have that Archimedes how do you
make marvelous
oh yeah that's who I want to see mm-hmm
also I mean look we'll see what happens
but I'm I'm all for Disney plus plus
they're coming out with a five dollar
price point for this so everyone's gonna
sign up for it I don't think there's a
lot of things that scare Netflix but I
would be willing to bet yeah for sure
we're you excited about the new moon
really quick before we say goodnight
100% yeah I'm Jennifer I'll act into the
trailer so far yeah especially the fact
that Nikki's behind the camera cuz I
think that's what they're also gonna do
forward get filmmakers that have an
identity and an attachment that's the
Kevin Feige thing up there yes all right
there we go well that's our discussion
about the new Lion King the 2019
live-action version that you can
currently keep track of on
rottentomatoes.com right now whether
it's days fret whether it goes back down
to rod
keep your eyes on that and obviously
come see us here at the after show you
can subscribe to our YouTube channel
right now and hit that Bell that's gonna
give you an alert every time we drop a
new after show love talking movies in
full detail with the all thanks to a
great panel and thank you all for
watching leave your comments below I'm
Mark Ellis and we'll see you next time
[Music]